GoPro cameras used to be one of the
hottest products on the market because
of the ease of use and versatility from
simply vlogging to caption underwater
footage GoPro cameras were one of the
best options but for a while now GoPros
have gone out of the spotlight as in you
rarely ever hear about them and this is
more than evident in their stock prices
which started in the 30s and 40s and
skyrocket for the first couple of years
but ever since mid 2015 they have been
on a constant downward spiral leaving
their stock price today at just two
dollars and seventy two cents
even ignoring the current market
downfall you can see that GoPro hasn't
been doing well for a while now so what
happened to GoPro well starting off
given their early success GoPro started
to overprice many of their cameras after
the release of the very popular hero4
cameras GoPro decided to follow up the
lineup with a mini hero4 session camera
which was outrageously priced at $400
the hero4 session had worse specs in the
hero4 silver and black however it was
50% smaller and 40% lighter and they
really tried to use this point to price
the session at the same foreigner price
point as the silver clearly consumers
were already content with the size of
the hero4 silver and saw no reason to
get the hero4 session when it was the
same price as a silver gopro ended up
cutting the price twice first at $300
and then to $200
moving on scarred from this experience
of low sales due to high pricing GoPro
tried to target more consumers by
offering more for a cheaper price but
this too backfired as this led the
cannibalization of their higher-end SKUs
in the same year as the hero4 session go
quote enters three low to mid range
products including the hero hero plus
and hero+ LCD the hero was quite
comparable to the hero4 silver and black
in terms of performance but the price
was much more favorable starting at $130
as the hero plus and hero+ LCD played a
similar role in the market consumers
just bought these parts over their
higher-end
furthermore not only did this reduce
their sales of the hero4 silver and
black but also reduced pricing
expectations from gopro forcing gopro to
settle at lower profit margins as you
can guess these moves severely hurt
GoPro causing her stock to drop lower
than their IPO of $24
as a result GoPro thought that it was a
swell idea to do a stock buyback
companies buy back their stock whenever
their stock is doing bad or if they just
want to inflate the stock value for any
reason they try to utilize simple supply
and demand tactics to drive up the price
if there is less stock on the market it
would become more valuable to investors
is the thought this may have worked if
they actually followed through with
their plan but once again they let this
fall through in late 2015 the company
announced that they would buy back 300
million dollars of stock but they ended
up only buying back 1.5 million shares
or thirty five point six million dollars
worth when GoPro themselves only ended
up buying back a little more than 10
percent of their initial commitment
investor conference further decrease
causing GoPros doctor quickly reached
the single digits meanwhile one of their
biggest corporate investors Foxconn
backed out
Foxconn who is the large manufacturer in
the world was an early investor in GoPro
in fact they bought a 8.8 eight percent
stock in the company before their IPO
but by late 2015
Foxconn disclosed that they had sold 30
percent of their shares to make things
worse report suggested that their ego
the chairman of Foxconn had lost faith
in GoPro moving on in 2016 GoPro tried
to diversify its business by developing
into the cloud backup space in late 2016
GoPro launched a cloud backup platform
alongside their hero 5 but they're late
entering the market along with the
stronghold Google and Apple already had
on the market made it very tough for
GoPro to gain any ground in a final
desperate attempt GoPro tried to further
diversify its business by jumping into
trendy products including VR and drones
GoPro actually formed a partnership with
YouTube to jumpstart their entry into
the market with the GoPro Odyssey
which was a $15,000 16 camera device but
very quickly Google realized that such
prices would not be very plain to
mainstream and though he didn't cut
their partnership with the GoPro they
started to make partnerships with other
camera manufacturers as well like he
technology as for the drone market there
were already many key players in the
market specifically DJI intubations who
dominated the high-end market in fact
you can often find their drones
showcased in Apple stores so they had
very reputable brand backing them to
make things worse the GoPro Karma their
new drone had an embarrassing recall
soon after the police after product so
you can see this venture didn't quite
pan out either on top of all of this
GoPros focus on these outside businesses
led to a further downfall in their main
business many of their newer products
look like copies of products that were
already on the market for instance the
hero4 session looked a lot like the
polaroid cube and the 360-degree fusion
closely resembles Samsung's gear 360 but
aside from all of these the truth is
that GoPro had a core problem that they
couldn't solve GoPros main repeating
customer base was sport and adventure
enthusiasts but the thing was these
customers didn't represent most in
revenue in the early days the main
reason GoPro blew up was because of the
average person's intrigue in getting a
GoPro this is what led to explosions in
the revenue numbers but once these
people had gotten a gopro their
curiosity was satisfied and the loss of
this revenue is what I really think
heard GoPro sure they made player
mistakes but I don't think they really
could done much to save this waning
demographic and that's what happened to
GoPro if you guys thought this video
explained the downfall of GoPro well
then make sure drop the like also make
sure to subscribe if you like see more
questions just like this one logically
answered but I told that I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one